this morning the worldwide coronavirus
death toll has reached one
million people it happened in less than
nine months
more than 205 000 of those victims are
americans and the rate of new infections
in the u.s
is on the rise again the trump
administration is launching a plan
announced last month to increase covid
testing
the goal is to help schools and
businesses reopen
safely our lead national correspondent
david begno is in new york city where
elementary schools are reopening for
in-person learning david
this is going to affect a lot of kids
and it's going to look dramatically
different anthony the people you see
assembled behind me are getting ready to
reopen this school as you said they're
reopening in phases today it's the
elementary school
and we found out of the 1.1 million
students in the new york city school
district which is the largest public
school system in the country
about 52 opted to come back for
in-person learning so
a pretty big number decided we wanted to
stay home and keep learning virtually
now today's reopening of school just
happens to come on the same day that the
white house says
we're rolling out millions more rapid
tests and here's why
we're announcing our plan to distribute
150 million abbott rapid point of care
tests
in the coming weeks that was president
trump on monday making good on a promise
that he made
a month ago he is rolling out what
appears to be a more robust
national copic testing strategy in part
the white house says
to help get kids back to school safely
one two
three four five into the test
and you wait 15 minutes the rollout is a
sharp pivot for the president
who for months dismissed the need for
increased covet tests
the rapid testing comes as a new study
shows an alarming
increase for coveted cases in america's
children
in the beginning of april kids accounted
for two percent of
all the positive covid test results by
september
that was over 10 percent dr yvonne
maldonado is a pediatric infectious
disease specialist
at stanford university we've heard that
all over the place
that children don't get infected that
they don't spread disease
and we know that's not true so having
said that however
children are less likely to be infected
with symptoms
than adults the average rate of new
coronavirus cases
is on the rise in at least 26 states
in utah recent cases are rising
it's also where alicia gettys lives with
her 16 year old son turner
turner runs track in cross country but
after recovering from coronavirus
earlier this year he has been sidelined
due to chest pains and difficulty
breathing
specialists told both lisha and turner
his problems
are likely related to covet the doctors
said we don't know
what's going to happen and we don't know
what the lasting side effects are
we need to be careful because none of us
know how it's going to affect any of us
because the pains wouldn't stop lisa
took turner to see a heart doctor a
cardiologist who examined his heart put
him through a battery of tests
and everything looked normal you know
gail it's a story that doesn't get
enough attention these people who
survive the virus
but then deal with lingering symptoms
for months to come
david i keep hearing about these stories
you feel so great that you've gotten
through it but
still there are things that you still
cannot get past i feel for turner what
are the options
well listen the doctor said just keep
doing what you do but he said if you
start to feel it as you start to run
you need to stop and let the body heal
its way forward
there's so much still unknown about
covet 19. thank you very much david good
to see you